[Music]
so when you're looking at bringing
partners on whether it's investment
partners whether it's business partners
like co-founder perspective those kinds
of things number one needs to be the
same values do you both care about
similar things in the world so values
need to align and then from from a skill
set perspective you need to be opposites
often dimes best friends are like we
want to start a business together it's
like the fastest way to not being
becoming best friends again being
opposites is so important I'm great at
design I'm great the vision I'm great at
the sort of the strategy I'm really
great at the aesthetic I'm really great
at the brand my partner needs to be grid
operations manufacturing warehousing
legal finance
all of that stuff that I don't love
doing can I do it little but I'd prefer
not to be I'd rather stay in my zone of
genius and have someone really really
take on their zone of genius and be in
mutual love one another
like I really believe that you know
there is that yin yang young that does
exist like if I have young energy
someone needs to having an energy to be
a real perfect partner I think to have
the right partner energetically you need
to be a match and skill set wise need to
be a match so yin yang like
energetically and then you know from a
skill set perspective we often like
we're like Oh both of us are super hyper
even if you have other other like skill
sets than I do that hyper hyper hyper
might not work and if it's hyper calm
like the calm counterpart calms me down
my hyperactive nez makes them more
excited you know so that energetically
works when you know when when it from a
skill set perspective I'm great at this
he's great at he or she's great at this
we're mutual love each other both
energetically and from a skill set
perspective that is the perfect partner
like I you know I've always looked for
that energy and skill set from well I
think so so I sit on the board of
conscious capitalism and I think
conscious capitalism is really based on
a stakeholder model like every single
person has to win and and I think in the
past has a little bit sloppy in the
stakeholder model and that we scaled so
quickly just put butts in seats fast
didn't really think about a lot of
things as your
scaling which happens to most
entrepreneurs and I think now it really
is you know with with tushie
I'm really really deliberate about the
type of people I bring onto the team
really checking their backgrounds think
they really fit before anyone gets hired
they have to make the whole team and
they have the team has to give me their
feedback on what they think about this
person if they drive well it really is
culture culture Trump strategy every day
of the week and twice on Sunday and you
know in the past I certainly was a lot
more sort of laughs oh you've a pulse
come join like we're busy you got to
grow and now it's like what's your
background
let me look your social media if it's
all selfies you know that's scary
that's all it's not a great person to
have on your team if it's like selfie
from every angle which means that they
might not be a great team player and so
and then calling references doing
background checks it's so important to
do that and I just didn't and I think to
really create that culture to really
scale a business requires doing that
real work and with tushi I'm so so
delivered my new my new CEO role you
know I've interviewed 50 people for the
company for this role to really be that
yin to my young and that opposite to my
you know my skill set and in the past it
had been like okay a few people let go
and now 50 people called all 10
references of every one of them and
really had them meet all the team to
make sure that they liked the person
really really important to do that
culture of fit test which I didn't do in
the past
[Music]
you